رغم التحديات التي انتقلت من عام 2022 الى
العام الجاري تشير توقعات الى ان سوق
السيارات العالميه سينمو بنسبه 4% ليصلها
عدد السيارات الى 74 مليون سياره وهو اقلب
حوالي 8% عن مستويات عام 2019 اي قبلا
اندلاع ازمات الوباء والطاقه والرقائق
والحرب وغيرها في الصين رجحت اكبر مؤسسه
لصناعه السيارات ارتفاع مبيعات السيارات
في البلاد بنسبه ثلاثه بالمئه لتصل الى 27
مليون و600,000 سياره في عام 2023 اما في
الولايات المتحده توقعت شركه جنرال موتورز
احدى اكبر شركات السيارات في العالم ان
تنتهي مبيعات السيارات في العام الجاري
عند 15 مليون وحده كما انه من المتوقع
تسجيل معدل نمو بخمسه بالمئه في دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي 27
رابطه التجاره الحره الاوروبيه والمملكه
المتحده لتصل الارقام الى 11 مليون سياره